لا توجد اي محل تجاريه تعمل حتى الان فقط
المواطنين الذين ياتون
للموظفين دوله للمدارس في كامل العاصمه هل
هناك دوام رسمي هل يذهب الطلاب الى
المدارس هل يذهبون الى مؤسساتهم جدا جدا
اغسل الكاميرا خلاص
اقفل الكاميرا خلاص اذا مشاهدينا نتابع
الان دوريه
لربما احد المكونين تطالب مراسل العربيه
من الخرطوم سالم الهاشمي باطفاء الكاميرا
اذا
كان بخير الحمد لله وهي قوه تتبع لقوات
الدعم السريع يستوثقون عن نقل الاحداث
وقالوا انهم يبحثون يجب ان ننقل ما هو على
الارض وان لا نزور الحقائق هذه هي
العبارات التي ذكرتها هذه القوه الان كانت
قوه من سيارتين تتبع للدعم السريع بالفعل
لكن لم يتعرضوا لنا نحن الحمد لله بخير
وحتى الفريق الموجود معي الحمد لله كلهم
بخير الان القوه تحركت مباشره وقدموا
اعتذارا لنا عن هذه المقاطعه